[Music]
[Applause]
uh let me bring in ryan clark of the
mothership the
former defensive back and uh kind enough
to join us here on
on short notice do you want to start afc
or nfc there right
listen it's your show damn man i'm just
honored to be on i start what you tell
me
all right let's start with the approach
the buffalo bills had
last night and what does tampa learn
from what buffalo did or didn't do
that you can't stop them no matter what
you pick but you think about
they think about what tampa did when
they played kansas city the first time
they did what we've seen them do
throughout the playoffs they went
man to man they were single high safety
and patrick mahomes carved them up for
over 400 yards
and so the buffalo bills went back to
something they did in week six
right where where patrick mahomes was
checking off to runs and
they ended up rushing for over 200 yards
but they kept the score down they only
scored 26.
what did he do differently this time
though he he went to the catch and run
he allowed travis kelsey he allowed
tyreke hill to get the ball in space and
have opportunities to create bigger
plays he got outside the pocket
and created second play opportunities
and so it's kind of pick your poison
when you play against the kansas city
chiefs your hopes are he gets it out of
his hand
fast enough to not create big plays but
if you can't tackle on the back end
which the buffalo bills didn't do last
night you're in trouble and so i think
you have to have a mixture of that but
more than anything ben
he can't read your mail before the play
if patrick mahomes knows where to go
with the football right away
if he knows if you're in single high
safety or if he knows if you're in cover
two
and he can get the ball out of his hands
quickly those guys that catch the ball
those skill players are much too good to
contain
and so todd bowles has a hard decision
on his hands
okay but you're a defensive player you
couldn't go into a game
as a player going we have no chance of
stopping them
right you wouldn't go in or or maybe you
would have you ever gone into a game
where you went we
we have no chance of stopping this this
quarterback or this offense
you know absolutely not and and the
tampa bay buccaneers won't feel that way
at all you know even carlton davis who
was burned for 200 yards in the first
quarter against tyreek hill
he's going to step up and feel like he
can do better this time especially after
matching up pretty well
with devonte adams yesterday but tyreek
hill is different travis kelsey
is different and so this is a game where
you need your defensive coordinator to
help you this is a game where you need
your offense
to run the football and keep patrick
mahomes off the field
as much as possible you know you don't
just defend patrick mahomes
with 11 people playing defense you
offend him you defend him with your team
you defend him with your strategy with
your scheme
and so yeah you feel like you can go out
there and play but i'm gonna tell you
this
in 2010 when aaron rodgers was at the
height of his aaron rodgers nist
we go to the super bowl and we played
extremely well there were plays i
planned to get interceptions there were
things coach lebeau knew
and we knew exactly what was coming and
we were right there able to make the
play
and his throw was better the placement
was better the velocity was better than
we were
and sometimes that's what you know i'm
not even gonna say sometimes
most of the times that's what you run
into when you play patrick mahomes
and many teams have seen that the last
two years in the playoffs
but can you i don't know if you disguise
when you're going to double cover kelsey
or when you're going to double cover
tyree kill because you can't double
cover both of them but
so how do you pick your poison each
series or each play or
you know each quarter you know that
that's what these two weeks are about
right these two weeks are about
understanding where they get the
football
and when they get it in the most
important moments and you can double
them and you can disguise
when you double it and you also know
that you have levonte david
and you have devon white right maybe the
best linebacking core in the nfl
definitely top three
and you look at that and you say you
know what it's going to be your job
to handle clyde edwards elaire it's
going to be your job to handle daryl
williams we're not going to
stack the front we're not going to put
eight people in the box if they choose
to run it
we feel like our guys are better than
their guys up front
and so if you do have to call a play
which we called in pittsburgh was double
the stars
right if you played a team that had two
threats if it was rob gronkowski and wes
welker writing you know you're going to
double the stars with a backer and a
safety you're going to lean the safety
to tyreek hill then you do those type of
things you just have to do it timely
and it's not necessarily about
describing this disguising it because
sometimes
i want you to know i'm doubling tyree
kill so you just throw it somewhere the
hell else i want you to know i'm
doubling travis kelsey so you can throw
it somewhere the hell else
and i think todd bowles is gonna have to
figure out when is the right time
to play too high single high double
blitz because if he catches you
and he knows it's coming there's nothing
you can do to stop it
what's it like when you're on the field
with somebody you know
is a whole lot faster than you like
tyreek hill
seems like frightening he's a whole lot
fast do you have a guy that you played
against where you went
that guy's a whole lot faster oh okay
and it didn't even take any thought
there's a play
there's a play the year after we win win
the super bowl dan and this is coming
off of the off season it's the first
game
it's a thursday night game you know the
coronation of the reigning champs and
we're playing cover two so i'm kind of
backside about nine yards off the ball
and they start with
run away from me and so would run away
run away i had to cut back right so i
couldn't overrun the ball
he starts back toward us he cuts back to
the back side
and i'm nine yards from the line of
scrimmage chris johnson is still behind
the line of scrimmage but i see that
he's gonna get outside
i didn't take a 45 degree angle i turned
my body directly to the goal line he was
going to
and i started running and not looking at
it
because i understood i wasn't going to
catch him the only reason i turned
around dad
was so when the film came on coach lebo
great effort rc the only thing that
helped me
is that troy played on our team and he
was somehow on game day the fastest
person in the world
and he ended up catching him 40 yards
down the field so the more to the story
is
chris johnson ran by me and troy
palamalu all at the same time
when i knew i was only running to show
that i had worked out in the off season
because i wasn't catching it
it's ryan clark of the mothership
joining us uh i i love what you tweeted
out about
scotty miller um ryan tweeted out
scotty miller is not like any of those
new england receivers i'm tired of
telling folks that
nothing about number 10 says bring his
lunch pail first
in last out coach on the field reads the
zone dude as a burner address him as
such
lol uh you should have tweeted that to
kevin king
prior to the game because he forgot that
scotty miller was a track guy this isn't
wes
welker or julian edelman yes
well you know you know you know what
happened what's funny is i tweeted that
before the play at the end of the second
quarter
so so this was i don't know i think they
replaced
cameron braid with scottie miller and he
runs out and they throw him the ball and
you know troy is going off about julian
edelman and wes welker you know
and listen guys i try not to bring race
into things but sometimes racial bias
plays a part and this wasn't my racial
bias it was troy
troy saw a short little white guy and he
thought all those other dudes
that had ever played with tom brady he
is not that dude
this is this is the dude that when you
do go to the track meet and i hope i can
say this on your show
when you do go to the track meet and he
wins the one the four by one
by coming back from last place and
beating all the other black dudes on the
track
they say hey man y'all seen that white
boy that's who scottie miller is
he's that fast he's that explosive and
he will embarrass you
and so i don't know what we have to do
to get scouting reports
around the world changed but this is
he's
none of those people now he may do all
those things he may be first in first
out
he's also first to finish every sprint
at practice
he's the fastest guy on the team he's a
deep ball threat and had kevin king
read my twitter or had he had his phone
on the sideline and maybe he wouldn't
have been
deep deep i think i need a faster name
for him ryan
like scotty miller doesn't i mean that
doesn't sound like a fast guy
i think it does i mean think about it
chris johnson that's a fast name
you know he had a great he had a great
nickname though
oh yeah we do i don't i mean white
lightning would obviously be
probably too racist how about smoke
miller
but but uh john brown is smoke in
buffalo oh
okay yeah but he's not in the playoffs
there's only two teams left in the
playoffs i don't know i don't know what
other like
jungle cat is as fast as that either
because tyrique's already playing on the
other side
um the decision by the packers to go for
the field goal
i can only tell you what i thought in
real time and i i didn't understand
the sequence of plays if you know you're
going to go for it on fourth down
i got to change what i'm going to do for
the other three downs but
um i'm curious what you saw and if you
agreed with what the packers were trying
to do
absolutely did not agree with what the
packers were trying to do i think
when you get in that position dan you
say this is four down territory
and now you start to call your plays
according to that
uh obviously you have the miss on the
miscommunication
on the slant uh then you have second
down then on third you know we're trying
to decide whether aaron rodgers runs or
does whatever
but i think if you call your plays
differently you're not in a position
where you're thinking of going for
fourth and eight or fourth and nine
you're closer to the goal line and you
can make those plays the other thing
that's confusing for me is you hear so
many times when people
are in the red zone they get a penalty
and you say oh the playbook now
opens up how come the playbook was
closed all of a sudden a sudden
and you have aaron rodgers i'm not sure
if you ever watch the fresh prince of
bel air
oh damn but here's what i thought about
what he essentially did was what colton
did
on the last shot of the game when he
stole the ball from will smith he didn't
give him a chance
and if you remember carlton threw that
ball over the over the basketball goal
and that's what happened when you when
you kicked that field goal and now
you're depending on your defense who has
kevin king on it
who played terrible all day you've taken
the ball out of the best player on your
team's hand
probably the mvp this season and what
struck me most about this is the reason
you're losing
the reason you're down at least a
touchdown is because bruce arians
trusted his hall of fame quarterback and
put him back on the field
late in the second quarter and they pick
up a fourth down then they throw that
football
to scotty miller to score you have to
have that same type of gumption those
same type of guts
you got to go win it in that moment and
to make that decision even when the
analytics tell you
it's not that big of a change if you go
for the field goal or not
is unacceptable did you ever uh
get a pick against brady of course not
he always brady beat our butt like every
time we beat him one time and it was
one of the trash talking tomorrow did he
try to kill him
no no he was actually i would give him
this i got the opportunity to talk to
him
my last year we were in washington we
were playing him he was actually highly
complimentary
of me and troy but i will say this the
year troy and i were both
out was the year anthony smith
guaranteed to win against the undefeated
patriot
he throws they he throws a touchdown
uh a bomb he throws a long pass uh
and runs 60 yards anthony smith ended up
being the guy beating the play run
60 yards to stand in front of anthony
smith and tell him about his guarantee
and when i saw that like it was like the
realest moment to me because i was like
here he is
you know six round pick uh a guy from
california
st extremely classy extremely
distinguished
and he chose to run 60 yards he didn't
have to to tell somebody about keeping
their mouth closed and that's when i
gained a lot of respect for the
competitor tom brady was
what do you think aaron rodgers was
saying after the game about his future
in green bay um i think this was the
first time
because of the way things ended aaron
rodgers
let himself look at the draft the draft
pick of jordan love in totality
um i think he he tried his best to be a
great teammate he tried his best to be a
great leader
and i think because he understood that
the perception of him was that he wasn't
going to do that the perception of him
was that he was going to make it hard
on jordan love and the green bay packers
i think he fought that all season and i
think he found some joy
in that and and i believe you get to
this position
um you don't win the you don't win the
nfc championship
your coach doesn't allow you to go for
it on fourth down
and then you start to let everything
weigh on you you know the pick
not getting an extra weapon not giving
me the opportunity to go on fourth down
maybe not having a chance to have an
extra playmaker that helped me win this
game and you say you know what
this may not be the place for me but
that's emotion talking i think he steps
away
and realizes he's 26 and six in the last
two season and he's been
seasons and he's been to the nfc
championship twice and he'll probably
settle down and understand let's go try
to get another run at this
would you want matthew stafford if
you're a contender and you need a
quarterback
i would i think matthew stafford is one
of the more underrated players
of his generation it's because he's been
in detroit his whole life
it's because he necessarily hasn't had
the pieces around him to win
this is a guy with this much arm talent
and
plenty arm talent to win football games
obviously we've seen the type of
toughness
that this man has because of the
beatings he's taking uh i think you have
to be the right team you know from the
san francisco
49ers somebody i look at i'm the
washington football team
it's a quarterback i look at if i'm the
indianapolis coach he's the quarterback
i take a look at i don't know if those
teams have what the detroit lions will
want to get him
but he's definitely a viable choice as a
starting quarterback in his league
yeah i don't know if it's just a first
round pick ryan right because it
if they decide why did they announce
publicly that they're parting ways why
why do you you lose leverage don't you
um i i think you definitely lose
leverage because if i'm another team out
there i said well
if we don't have the trade capital or
want to give up the trade capital
it will take to get him then they're
gonna probably just release him anyway
why not play that game why not play the
free agent game or maybe there's a team
that wants him so much believes he's so
vital
to their success or believe that they're
one matthew stafford away from winning a
championship that does come
with what's tape what what's needed or
what detroit wants to get him
um i think that for me i don't announce
it
or maybe you just announce it so teams
know that matthew stafford has the
ability
to start talking about a trade and what
that would look like for him and for the
detroit alliance
case i don't talk to you before the
super bowl who do you got
as long as patrick mahomes is alive i'm
probably going to pick him to win
every single game he plays in so i got
the chiefs
you're going to bet against tom brady i
am okay but not with real money
[Laughter]
hey you're doing great we appreciate you
joining us and
hope to have you on again thank you ryan
man thank you so much
that's uh ryan clark